with over 300 sessions at next 2023 it's
understandable that you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see an
introduction to do at AI in Google Cloud
then stay tuned because here's the
[Music]
rewind generative AI is top of mind for
us for our customers and for the
industry at the moment but we've been at
this a long time we have our solutions
for consumers like Bard and maker Suite
and our Enterprise ready options like
vertex Ai and duet Ai and for each gen
aai solution there's so many different
use cases with varying requirements
especially on the Enterprise side with
such a wide variety of industries from
media to retail to financial and
Healthcare Services there's a lot to
consider when it comes to Enterprise
ready gen endtoend data sovy data
control fraud and security protections
Integrations with existing data data and
applications not to mention some basic
Cloud concerns too how much time will it
take to get up and running make sense of
the data and start innovating with these
systems by putting the power of
generative AI in the hands of millions
of Google Cloud users of various
backgrounds and skill levels we're
reimagining the cloud experience and
freeing up more time and money to focus
on more valuable work and that's where
duet AI comes in assembled on top of
vertex AI with a foundation in Google
Deep Mind and integrated across Google
Cloud products duet AI uses generative
AI to provide contextual assistance
wherever you need it from Cloud idees to
the cloud console or via chat assistant
you can build no code apps optimize
costs explore your data in big query and
even secure your applications all while
saving valuable time and energy in fact
One customer who tested du at aai with
their developer saw a 33% increase in
productivity and that's definitely worth
looking into so let's check out some of
the core game-changing functionality of
duet AI duet AI currently has five key
features assisted development assisted
operations assisted data assisted no
code development and assisted security
with assisted development functions are
generated based on comments your code is
completed as you type
errors are automatically corrected and
you can even chat with an AI pair
programmer about the code with assisted
operations you can get critical how-to
information about gcp infrastructure
deployment and best practices and even
recommendations for optimizing your
Cloud applications for cost security
reliability and
performance with assisted data you can
discover and explore your data and
insights learn and build with assisted
coding translate code dialects and
automate data enrichment and wrangling
for low hassle reliable
analytics with assisted no code
development you can have a simple
natural language-based chat conversation
to model data create and customize apps
for your specific business needs and
design and deploy automated
workflows with assisted security you get
up-to-date security insights on major
Bad actors automated alerts for breaches
and lateral movements and best practice
guidance on remediation
steps and that's really just the start
our road map includes enhancements in
all those areas and richer functionality
across the board while generative AI is
top of mind for many right now Google's
longtime innovation in this space will
continue to help our customers and our
users reduce time spent searching for
Solutions dealing with frustrating
knowledge silos
even limitations in technical knowledge
and when you get that time back when the
tools work for you and with you imagine
what you can create if you'd like to see
the full talk check out the link in the
description and don't forget to
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more great next rewind content thanks
for
[Music]
watching